hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to markiplier my name is
Mark a game that was obviously made by a
fan by the name of girl plays stuff so
thank you so much for making this for me
I can't wait to see what it's all about
I always love these fan games that
people make for me I hope it's fantastic
and I know it is so thank you so much
chapter one the end is a new beginning
yes whoo splash
are we going swim swimming hello whoa
cool
markiplier mark my name is Mark wait can
I now remember who is what wait a minute
Marga Blaire who is me I'm the most
hands Oh stupid clock I get to voice
myself you put on your glasses in your
wharfs - you know like I do every
morning it's almost 8 p.m. is it that
time already I need to replace my clock
why would I be waking up at 8 p.m.
I guess VidCon was too overpowering even
for markiplier I actually didn't go to
VidCon this year or last year ever I
should at least record something let's
go see if Bob and Wade are up for some
drunk minecraft which we may be
recording very very soon
speak of the devil you got it oh is that
like a Skype remix here hey look it is
hey bark you won't believe what Wade has
been saying what blade oh it's not a lie
I went to putters here is
I went up utters it's like this grilling
bar and there were girls they're not
Hooters kind of girls Oh anyway I got
this models number this international
supermodels number ah I get absolutely
nothing it's a strategy I like to call
the penis flytrap oh God
wait that's some great a [ __ ] if
it's a model then her standards are
pretty low this is an actual
conversation we had while we were
reporting drunk minecraft wait you're
just pretty average zombie can you tell
Bor wait somewhere far far away
zombie hello bout an hour later
boo I'm all pooped out and apparently
really really drunk I should at least
get some fresh air
you got it me through the window to the
wall through the sweat drop off my brow
so anyway
obviously not there oh I guess that's
the exit whoosh ah this looks like a
decrepit in testitude neighborhood
exactly like home where am i this place
doesn't remotely look like my place from
the outside at all bark
what hello who's there I'm over here
mark Oh Oh God
it's tiny box Jim oh my little bit no no
come over there over there over there
Oh DynaVox doom I are your sake out oh
god yep always will be here whenever you
need me
yeah you will but you seem to be in a
real bind this time I don't know where I
am
it seems that I'm in some sort of
parallel universe and yet I early talked
to Bob and Wade well I'm here now to
help
I forgot what tiny box Tim's voice
actually sounds like I did it back in
that amnesia it was amnesia elate wait a
minute why is there another oh I thought
there were two a dark tiny bugs Tim huh
damn it's locked
well I guess I should have expected
barging in on my neighbor like that
hello look a sign all that we see or
seem is but a dream within a dream so
it's totally inception up in here whoa
hello
it's the saved point and dynabox dam is
level 99 so cool oh I knew you stuff I
knew he was tough as nails he didn't
need me to defend him from those boxes
that made fun of him
great it's raining everywhere I look
there's no sign of anyone I'll protect
you mark thanks tiny Buck Tim I love you
I always have you'll always be my little
biscuit wait a minute what's up here is
there something up there it's a like
earthbound where there was a thing in
the woods where you can go in deep I
sounded wrong what is Endemol okay it's
just a rock nevermind
hello is anybody here anybody lost in
these woods this is the woods that lead
to the witch's house it suddenly stopped
raining that's weird
ah the lovely music I used to use this
music for every single vlog ever and it
got really old but it always was always
very touching music to me I liked it a
lot
so anyway locked there should be a key
somewhere but where up your button
around the corner that's where yeah hey
ah that glowy glowy looks exactly like a
key may I have it
rusty house key was wrong I'm so awesome
and finding keys even in vanish yes even
in van wait no not that game Marga bar
begins his rant I beat that game I don't
need to do a rant about it I beat it I
beat it fair and square
I don't care about all the people that
said that I didn't beat it four hours
later and I just realized I was actually
about to go on a rant about that but
anyway and then people died I think we
should just keep going probably for the
best idea by sim thank you for listening
to my story you've always been so
patient with me I do appreciate it and
love you even more for it and especially
all of you out there ah then I was good
so happy well what
no the door is unlocked the rusty door
key shattered well good I always get so
happy when I play these fan-made games
chapter 2 never forget the house you
grew up in hello
just can't back out now Hey look there's
a paper post oh that was though almost
Oakton ID there's a paper post on the
wall I'll be tiny box Tim's voice from
now on okay let's go read the paper post
otherwise known as a piece of paper
sometimes people forget their own
greatness not me
I'm fantastic okay that found an orb
this might come in handy huh the soul is
a special or which I've be stirred upon
you this will allow you to save at any
point of the game but be wary this is
the only time I will help you so use it
wisely or else haha
have fun okay thank you it's locked
damn it well I need to find another key
are you big box Barry is this big butt
whoo-hoo-hoo-hoo hello do bro hahahaha
this could only mean one thing we must
venture into the depth below you and
your large words Oh tiny box Tim you
know you're smarter than me
they say that if you dream about going
down a flight of stairs it represents
our innermost thoughts that music sounds
familiar
oh god was that from the creek no that
wasn't for the crewmen what game was
that from it sounds so familiar or does
that man father the memories we've once
forgotten
so come down mark there's something I
want to show you is it good or bad or is
it oh boy it's bad it's probably bad
Donnie boxing will protect me I need not
fear anything with tiny bucks Tim on my
side and my fans who believe in me I
know that you guys just want me to
encounter jump scare excuse me oh oh
what what what huh I don't make no sense
what wait a minute what is that even
while they're able to walk into the wall
oh good it's okay oh and so is his house
oh that's what it is ah my favorite
favorite beyond favorite RPG horror I've
ever played the mannequin in blue the
mannequin in the suite is always telling
the truth the sweet the mannequin in
pink I heard that the mannequin ensue
the sweet is a bully but always tells
the truth the mannequin and the sweet is
a liar if you believe me go on the door
and the left what the mannequin in the
suite ah the mannequin in red is a vixen
hmm if you don't believe me don't take
the door on the left but take the door
on the right
well just because she's a vixen doesn't
mean that she's bad why do you guys
always go to assume things about each
other maybe you're all good
maybe there is that meaning but blue
said that the man in the suite always
tells the truth and man on suite is a
bully but I don't know
I don't know what I want me to do
uh-huh right oh oh okay that sounds bad
oh that sounds like that oh boy
well okay something's munching on my
bones
please I need that femur a man's word is
weighted by honesty the fool did I died
I died okay game over everybody thank
you so much for watching I'll see you in
the night what I said whatever I'm not
even gonna listen to the man in the
suede I'm not even gonna listen to you
here I go a screw you guy oh okay now it
works just fine even though Ock may what
does Ock may mean Kum Kee thank you I am
mo let's play hey yay I love games me
and tiny buy your boy Hayes I hate mazes
Macy's Oh who's that who's that little
girl over there
you see something that I should
definitely avoid can I save oh that's a
cool screen oh it's so cool-looking tiny
like still over there oh he's so
adorable
dynamaxx em you'll defend me right oh oh
oh yes okay me oh yeah little girl
obtain the key good this will unlock the
other door and then I'll go away forever
and never have to bother by you again Oh
No thank you I don't want any go away
little girl you're a very creepy but
probably not tiny box in would able to
clock you one right in the face
let's get outta here
what does that even mean the door is
unlocked the rusty door key shattered
wait
no rusty dorky already shattered oh
hello huh well the witch's house huh
I see IUB there's a hole behind this
painting but how do we get past it hmm
with my epic fists of fury I'm guessing
this needs to be symmetrical again but
how can things be it's not quite the
rooms too big
unless it's not supposed to be
symmetrical either oh it's the kitchen
from the witch's house I love love the
witch's house which oh oh no the door
locked itself I have to figure something
out maybe if I stand on the blood stain
oh well I guess I did good kill me the
last time this door makes me unnerving
well chapter 3 facing my ultimate fears
mannequins
okay no hi wait a minute did I miss an
easter egg or something was I supposed
to be able to figure out how to do that
damn it I hope I didn't miss something
mystic cross was found I have a bad
feeling huh it's a note this cycle is
never ending the rest of the page was
smeared I got a feeling I missed
something I feel bad oh I can't go back
I gotta go back I gotta go back guys run
away little girl no me no no okay so I
guess I looked and I couldn't find a way
to get past it so I have no idea what I
was willing to do I'm sorry if I miss
anything important I really am oh not
crazy
I'm not crazy what are you talking about
whatever was crazy why didn't I notice
that before because you're crazy I'm not
the crazy one here okay
so when I went back here yeah that door
did appear huh whoa music got
interesting what have you got for me oh
yeah No who are you ah your other half
mark are you that emo vampire
your dark half then I'll destroy you
with the dark one then disc tisk tisk
what makes you think you can I don't
know unless I try I'm my black well you
can never get rid of me if you do I will
return
just like yin and yang those opposites
and yet without one another
everything will crumble okay I don't
really have an option here take that you
fool
ah now you banished forever and ever
never to awaken again from your slumber
oh now I can go back okay I get it I get
it now I'm able to go back in this be
able to go through the thing okay look
the painting is gone you got a tiny box
Tim I am out of here you will never
leave Oh tonight oh oh there I go again
markiplier oh it's cyclical mark my name
is oh this is the never-ending nightmare
that I live every day of my life oh I go
to bed and then I wake up and then I
have to kill my other half and then I go
do it all over again ah perfect stupid
clock the end ah that's pretty cool that
was really cool it actually had a good
story there was some you know English
typos but I'm assuming that the person
who made this not a native English
speaker which is perfectly
understandable hey thank you so much for
making this that actually was really
cool and it had an interesting story to
it like no joke thank you so much for
making it
oh my god and that's the end of it so
seriously thank you so much I'm always
on the lookout for these awesome fan
made games because you guys have
such an inspiration for me and I'm
always eager to play them so send them
to me whatever way you can I know it's
hard to get in touch with me personally
but just try try try don't stop trying
just in general and just in life also
seriously you guys are the reason why I
do this you guys have so much potential
to make cool stuff like this I mean if
you can make this make a full-fledged
game you don't do it go out there and do
it spend the time I believe that you
guys can do whatever the hell you want
to because you guys are absolutely
amazing I don't mean to make this some
silly inspirational thing but the music
is playing and I just feel like thanking
you guys for being here for me every
single day and supporting me
you're awesome you're the reason I do
this you're the reason I get up and live
that cycle where I have to kill my evo
vampire and I'm sorry for making fun of
dark attire
he's not an emo vampire he's really cool
guy that there's a lot of different fan
versions of dark blue seriously check
out tumblr there's like 10 different
versions of dark applier each unique to
some person and they're all cool so
thank you guys so much for being awesome
every single day no matter what don't
let anyone tell you that you're anything
but awesome so thanks again and as
always I will upload you liberal ah
they're all list all the other fan made
games in the description down there
below so that you guys can check it out
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye wait I guess I should have
dragged this on because dammit Iams I
screwed it up it was gonna be perfect
the ending of this up oh and now it's
gone now I'm staying to on now just oh
the music started over again I'm just
screwing everything up over and over
never thought I was gonna so this great
party's over there what's that what you
just said